♪ ♪ ♪
- Et on n. Donc, première
journée de campagne, c'est
très important de faire bonne
impression. Est-ce réussi
pour François Legault,
SÉBASTIEN BOVET
- Vous s a des moments
importants dans une campagne
électorale : la première
semaine aussi. Alors, ce que
les partis essaient de faire
en cette première journée,
c'est d'imposer un enjeu,
l'enjeu qui leur aimportant.imp,
François Legault l'a bien joué,t
que les Québécois lui font
confiance. Et il a posé une
pour?" Et le "pour" se décline
de plusieurs façons :s :s :s :
pour l'inflation, combattre
l'inflation, pour le réseau
québécoise. Il s'est
probablement fait dire que
c'était... ça pouvait marquer
les esprits, cette question
qu'il pose aux Qué il
n'attaque... il se positionne,
mais il mais il mais il mais ilt
ses adversaires. Probablement
qu'il s'est fait dire : "C'est
tes adversaires, ça paraît
mal." Mais il le fent
pas, attaquer ses adversaires
de front, qu'il ose même pas
Anglade, la cheffe du Parti
libéral, qui devient
"la madame". Et ça, c'est
un faux pas dans cette première
journée
Donc, il a bien circonscrit,
je pense, la question qu'il faus
en même temps, ça nous rappelle
ablement que le pire
ennemi de François Legault,
c'est François Legault,rale,ral,
qu'il est jamais loin d'unepelue
lui-même sur sa route.
- Bon, maintenant, partis d' pa,
c'est d'arriver, de se présenter
comme l'option de rechange
à la CAQ. Donc, qui s'en est
sorti le-y par les partis.
Le Parti libéral, Dominique
Anglade revient à l'ADN de son
parti, c'est-à-dire en mettant
Mais en même temps, elle l'avoue
elle-même : les Québécois
la connaissent mal. Donc, il y a
une recherche d'identité
qu'en 35-36 jours, elle va avoir
le temps de défini
identité? C'est un gros défi.
Le fait de commencer sa campagne
sans candidats derrière elle
aussi, cêtre pas être pas être e
qu'il y a de plus mobilisateur.
a mobilisé ses candidats :
75 qui étaient présents
dans la région de Sherbrooke.
Mais la démonstration que Québec
que son programme est crédible,n
des gaz à effet de serre.
C'est lesur ce plan-là. Qu'est-a
va vouloir dire da
Il y a une démonstration
à faire.e
dans ses convictions,
dans ses principes,
dans la fondation du parti,
de langue française. Vous allez
este plus
grand-chose d'autre
pour le Parti québment, qui esse
de sauver les meubles avant
de construire un premier
et un deuxième étage bâtis
Et quant au Parti conservateure
Éric Duhaime parler
de l'infil faut qu'il fasse
la démonstration q
c'est autre chose que des
frustrés des mesures sanitaires
et qu'il a une plateforme
électorale qui se tient. Donc,
démonstration de c
pour M. Duhaime à faire encore.
- Merci beaucoup, Sébastien,
on se reparle un petit peu
plus tar